It's not going to come as a surprise to most
people in our audience that when it comes
to factual knowledge, right now we have a
president that doesn't, yeah,
no much about economics, doesn't know much
about trade, doesn't know much about currency,
doesn't know much about finances or debt other
than personal debt or credit or jobs or any
of it.
But that has not stopped president Trump from
having very strong opinions about all of these
things for sure.
But in addition to not knowing about any of
these things, Donald Trump has another interesting
quality, which is that he's completely out
of touch with the average American.
So in other words, because he's been rich
for a long time, he got rich by building a
business.
Well, his family was already rich.
He personally built his wealth, uh, by creating
a business on the back of a small loan of
$1 million from his dad, and then even more
money from his dad.
You have to take that privileged status and
combine it with his ignorance on so many of
these financial issues.
And that's where you really get an understanding
that Donald Trump, by the combination of lacking
knowledge and being completely out of touch
with the way that the average person lives,
he can't possibly understand your financial
situation and clearly he doesn't understand
your financial situation.
Here is Donald Trump being asked about recession.
Recession fears have no fear.
Walmart is doing well.
Trump says, and everyone's rich.
So how could we possibly end up with a recession?
I don't think we're having a recession.
We're doing tremendously well.
Our consumers are rich.
I gave a tremendous tax cut and they're loaded
up with money at their buying.
I saw the Walmart numbers there were through
the roof just two days ago.
Uh, that's better than any poll.
It's better than any economists and most economists
actually say, Phil, that we're not going to
have a recession.
Most of them are saying when I can have a
recession, but the rest of the world is not
doing well like we're doing the rest of the
world.
If you look at Germany, if you look at a European
Union, frankly, look at the UK.
I mean, look at a lot of countries, they're
not doing well.
China is doing poorly.
Parts of Asia are doing poorly,
right?
Walmart's doing well and people are rich,
so everything's fine and a recession would
be impossible.
This is what happens when you combine total
ignorance on all things economic with weaponized
narcissism and the life of blinding privilege,
literally blinding privilege that blinds him
from understanding what the world is like
for most people.
Now, what's fascinating is that Donald Trump
isn't merely saying there can be recession.
He's saying if there is one on the off chance
that there is one, it will have been the media's
fault as an attempt to get them to lose the
2020 election.
So we can now continue to build our picture
ignorant on all financial and economic related
matters, blinded by ignorance, weaponized
narcissism and a level of paranoia that rises
to the level of diagnostic.
If there were to be a recession, we would
blame the media who has been reporting on
me in such a way to cause the economy to go
into a recession.
This is the trend under Donald Trump stocks.
Did well this month.
Oh, Donald Trump deserves the credit.
Of course, stocks did poorly this month.
It was the Fed, it was the media, it was China,
it was whoever the president can think of.
But the most disappointing and outrageous
thing is this idea that everybody is doing
well financially.
Trump doesn't see, and when I'm, when I say
that, I don't mean he refuses to recognize.
He's just not exposed to the reality that
40% of Americans can't afford an unexpected
$400 expense without having to go into debt,
take out a loan, go to a payday loan place,
borrow money or whatever the case may be.
Start charging stuff at interest.
Trump sees his cabinet, his golf members,
his family, the people he interacts with every
day, and that's it.
Everybody's rich.
How could we possibly have a recession when,
excuse me, when Trump says everyone is rich,
I guess he means everyone that matters to
him is rich.
Everyone that he needs to please is rich.
So there's the message from Donald Trump.
We definitely would not be having a recession
because everybody's rich.
But if we did, it would be normal because
other countries are having recessions and
it would be the fault of the Fed and China
and the media.
Definitely not his fault if that were to happen,
this counts.
I mean, we've fallen so far in terms of what
counts as political positioning and discussion
in 2019 America that that position counts
as a political position.
Trump's been doing great and stocks are flying
high, except when they're not.
It's because of the Fed and China and the
fake news media.
Whenever I see these headlines, Trump says,
can't have a recession because everyone's
rich.
I still have a reaction in my brain, deepen
my brain.
That is a pre-trump reaction, which is there
is no way that an American president would
ever say this, and that's, by the way, after
having lived through two terms of George W.
Bush, I still have that reaction in my brain.
Trump used a sharpie or, or someone in Trump's
administration and use the Sharpie to change
the path of Hurricane Dorian on a chart, which
we'll get to later.
That can't be true.
Oh, but it is.
It is true.
And then I look at the quote or I look at
the video, or I hear from one and one of Donald
Trump's flunkies.
And not only are the headlines typically accurate,
the reality of actually reading the quotes
or looking at the video are often even worse
than the headlines even suggest.
I hope that his voters will hold them accountable.
Now, I don't want a recession.
I know that there's a contingent on the left,
very small that wants a recession in order
to, to, to remove Donald Trump.
That's not me.
There's a big contingent of the right that
claims much of the left once a recession to
remove Trump.
That's based on a completely false assessment
of the left.
I want a good economy.
If we get one and uh, uh, uh, Donald Trump
is reelected or not reelected, the economy
being good is good for many people, even though
it still doesn't work for tens of millions
of Americans.
If we do get a recession, I still don't want
one.
If Donald Trump's supporters recognize that
it's because of him, at least partially that
the recession was precipitated, then the question
becomes will that make them vote for a democrat?
Because if not, then it's all merely academic
and hypothetical.
So that's what I want to talk about next,
how our consumers as Donald Trump refers to
them feeling about not only the state of the
economy, but Donald Trump's role in it now
and his potential role in a future recession.